Somewhere along
this journey, you
may see some personality
quirks that are weird.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Every scene in a movie is
trying to accomplish something.
Do all the things that
you have in your mind that
will inform the audience
when they see this character.
Oh, that's who that is.
After taking this
class, you will
be able to walk into a room,
present your best self,
and be happy with the result.
We are living in a
world of make believe.
So make it up.
When you're at home
preparing, you break down
what he's trying to convey--
the person he's speaking
to and to the audience.
The truth is, it's
who you are inflicted
upon the truth of the
dialogue that's written there.
And we all have comfort zones.
The hard work,
sometimes, as an actor
is getting out of
your comfort zone.
If you have a personal biography
for your character, that's
a way to get inside
of it and figure out,
you know, why does
he talk this way?
Is he a loner?
Does he have friends?
Is he a cynic?
Learn what acting techniques
are in other cultures.
You might find it more
interesting than the way
we normally do it.
In an audition,
don't say to them,
I don't think my character would
do that because your character
won't do that because
you won't be hired,
and you won't be
getting that check.
I made a decision
early in my life
that I wasn't gonna live and
die in Chattanooga, Tennessee.
Being able to embody a lot of
different characters in film
has been very cathartic,
being able to let
go of the anger or
the disappointment
that I had in my life.
Essentially, we're entertainers.
Find a way to make
yourself special.
Give it something that
will distract people
from their daily
lives in a way that
allows them to live in this
moment with us for a while
and leave there energized
by it and love it.
I'm Samuel L. Jackson, and
this is my MasterClass.